eh bien je dois dire que ma première
réaction a été été assez irrité assez
furieux parce que je pense que healy a
suffisamment de grands cinéastes qui
reste à découvrir qui ont fait leurs
preuves pour ne paraissait pas très
utile de s'intéresser à moi je trouve ça
très flatteur qu'on s'intéresse à moi
mais ça me paraissait un peu tôt c'est à
dire que justement j'ai 31 ans j'ai fait
cinq films et j'ai l'impression d'être
j'espère enfin je touche du bois au
départ de d'une plus longue recherche
qui peut être à ce moment là constituera
une oeuvre si vous voulez cela dit ce
café chapier justement n'est pas du tout
une chose exhaustive il n'a pas du tout
essayé de m'en cadrée de d'expliquer ce
que je suis et ce que je serai toute ma
vie c'est une espèce d'ouverture pour
peut-être plus tard expliqué ce que
seront les films que je ferai ensuite et
qui j'espère seront vraiment une oeuvre
chapitre ne vous a pas surpris vous
d'avoir écrire ou d'écrire un livre sur
ma mort je dois dire que c'est moi qui
ai demandé à louis malle son accord est
un critique de cinéma moi même il m'a
semblé intéressant d'essayer d'analyser
ce que l'uimm à la paix lui-même un
premier cycle une espèce de départ vers
autre chose je trouve que dans le cinéma
moderne il y a une façon d'aborder
certains problèmes qui nous préoccupent
tout ce qui n'existe qu'à c'est peu dans
la jeune littérature d'aujourd'hui qui
est plus fermé ou un autre et il m'a
semblé intéressant de dégager quelques
thèmes essentiels et vous parlez d'une
oeuvre de louis malle justement je parle
d'une oeuvre en effet au début du livre
mais quand on lit le livre on s'aperçoit
tout de même que je n'essaie pas de
fermer complètement
la carrière de lui mal je parle d'un
premier cycle mais on peut déjà parler
d'une oeuvre parce que si on prend son
premier film ascenseur pour l'échafaud
et dont on a toujours dit qu'il était un
exercice de style et dont j'ai c'est moi
de démontrer justement qu'il contenait
déjà en germe à peu près tous les thèmes
qu'il abordera par la suite je crois
qu'on peut parler d'une oeuvre parce que
il s'en dégage une morale une certaine
façon de voir les choses et surtout
chose qui m'a paru intéressante
louis malle au contraire des jeunes
cinéastes sa génération ne passe pas le
temps à se raconter lui même il jette un
regard sur le monde qui les entoure cela
ne veut pas dire qu'ils se refusent à la
confession mais il se raconte tout en
refusant la confession direct et lui
même ne se prend jamais comme héros
comme personnage principal
j'avais essayé je crois une fois oui
c'est à dire que j'ai essayé une fois de
d'écrire un scénario qui serait
franchement autobiographique et j'ai
c'était juste avant de faire le feu
follet et je me suis donné un mal de
chien et j'ai essayé de raconter des
choses qui m'étaient réellement arrivé
et dans un cadre qui a été le mien
pendant plusieurs années c'est à dire
une certaine vie à paris dans un certain
milieu et cette expérience a été un
désastre parce que je me suis aperçu
tout de suite que je franchis c'est
vraiment un certain nombre de barrières
que ce toujours voulu pour l'instant me
presser devant
mes films en fait il ya certaines choses
que je n'ai pas envie de dire aux parce
que j'ai le sentiment que je vais dire
est mâle ou d'une façon qui me paraît
trop impudique ou ou pas juste ou forcés
ou prématurée prématurée est ce que vous
me dire ce que son beau film pour vous
dans cet esprit c'est à dire que je
crois que c'est un problème qui est
celui de toute personne qui qu'ils aient
envie de à travers un moyen d'expression
quelconque de trouver de ce trophée
il ya au départ je crois une
contestation et un refus je crois que si
quand j'avais les stations ckoi une
révolte
oui c'est à dire que quand j'avais 18
ans si j'avais trouvé que le monde était
parfaitement en ordre que les gens au
milieu desquels je vivais était était
absolument épatant sans aucune réserve
et si j'avais trouvé que le monde
s'ouvrait devant moi comme une chose
très simple comme un comme un livre
d'imagés idéal
je crois que j'aurais pas eu envie de
faire des films et ce qui m'y a poussé
c'est qu'effectivement j'ai partant d'un
certain milieu qui était le mien que
j'ai commencé à contester je me suis mis
à contester finalement toute chose et
cette pensée cette contestation qui a
d'abord été si vous voulez j'ai
poursuivi à travers le temps où j'étais
étudiant ensuite quand j'ai commencé à
travers des films il s'est passé que ces
films chaque cas qui allaient dans des
sens très différents étaient chacun
quand même le terrain de justement de ma
part d'une recherche et d'une mise en
cause et de et je crois que ce qui en
fait la grande chose qui m'a poussé la
curiosité le refus d'un certain nombre
d'évidences et m'a semblé tout de même
qu' il fallait se faire soi même sont
son propre tour d'horizon ce qui fait
que je crois que les gens sont assez
surpris par parce que j'appuie appelle
mon oeuvre parce qu'en fait c'est
apparemment c'est pas du tout eu neuf
sont des films qui parlent dans toutes
les directions et qui sont très
différents d'un film à l'autre
chaque fois que j'ai fait un film le
film suivant j'essaye de le faire
apparemment et superficiellement le plus
différents possibles et par le sujet et
par les moyens employés et même par le
style et parce que pour moi c'est un
petit peu c'est toujours c'est ce
procédé de recherche qui consiste à
prendre une certaine un certain chemin à
m'engager dans ce chemin et pour
l'instant je crois que ça a été un petit
peu la morale négatif de tous les films
que j'ai fait jusqu'à présent à
m'apercevoir que ce chemin était une
impasse alors à revenir en arrière et à
essayer dans une autre direction
je le fais du reste avec un grand
enthousiasme enfin c'est pas du tout une
une quête désespérée ou absurdes ou ou
pessimiste enfin j'espère sincèrement
surtout maintenant j'ai l'impression
d'être arrivé quand même une plus grande
maturité à tous points de vue
j'espère un jour découvrir ma voie
royale en restant vous travaillez à
l'étoile peut-être je travaille en
étoile où j'ai l'impression d'être au
centre d'un labyrinthe et de chercher la
sortie et si je ne pensais pas la
trouver je serais très très triste très
désespéré ce que je ne suis pas va être
pas pessimiste finalement non en foire
tout cas je serais je serai optimiste le
plus longtemps possible
autrement dit on ne peut pas vous
demander dites-nous film par queen de
quoi chacune nous a libérés non mais
c'est c'est assez facile à trouver si
vous voulez je sais par exemple de quoi
les amants m'ont libéré ils m'ont libéré
d'une certaine hypocrisie sociale qui me
choque énormément ne choque toujours du
reste et et
peut-être maladroitement t'exprimer
parce que ça n'est pas un film dont je
suis très content j'ai essayé de montrer
que c'est un film assez idéaliste en
face et décide de montrer qu'il y avait
dans l'amour des réserves de lyrisme qui
pouvait faire exploser certaines
conventions sociales
c'est un film assez naïf en fait est que
j'ai fait comme ça à peu dans l'
enthousiasme parce que j'étais j'étais
très jeune j'avais 25 ans je les fais et
si vous voulez que je vous prends mon
dernier film le feu follet
pour moi ce n'est pas du tout une
apologie du suicide
ça n'est pas non plus un personnage dans
laquelle je me reconnais volontiers ça
n'a absolument pas autobiographique
pas du tout c'est simplement pour moi
une sorte d'exorcisme et j'essayais
d'exorciser non pas une tentation de
suicide qui n'a jamais été mon cas
vraiment mais une certaine part que je
trouve médiocre de moi-même et de d'un
certain nombre de gens au milieu
desquels je vis qui est un espèce de
refus de la vie qui arrivait un certain
âge prend des proportions assez
dramatique parce que il vient d'un
moment on ne peut plus se contenter
d'être un perpétuel adolescents et il
faut vraiment s'engager dans des routes
qu'ils soient des routes dom afin qu'il
soit il faut faire un certain nombre de
choix et il faut prendre le si vous
voulez le personnage du feu follet est
un personnage qui qui en fait va de
refus un refus et qui finalement le
refus suprême étant le suicide
si vous voulez et ça c'est une il y en
lui ce que peut-être j'ai regretté que
les gens n'aient pas assez vu une façon
précise il y en lui une une pour moi une
certaine médiocrité
j'ai pour lui beaucoup d'attachement ce
comme un frère est quelqu'un que j'ai
beaucoup de tendresse même temps moi
personnellement je le juge assez
sévèrement et il y en lui des tentations
et des certaines choses que je voudrais
écarté noire poussée très lourde après à
qui vous tourner le dos c'est un frère à
qui je voudrais vraiment tourné le dos
je sais pas si j'y arrive à moudre dans
l'échappée lorsque vous avez écrit ce
livre vous avez appréhendé
oui mal comme un écrivain en fait comme
un critique littéraire appréhendant
l'écrivain oui je dois avouer que je me
suis même livré à une sorte
d'explication de texte je crois que
elle peut paraître arbitraire au premier
abord parce qu on me dira toujours qu'un
film n'a rien de commun avec un livre
oui c'est peut être vrai si l'on voit
les choses un peu superficiellement mais
si l'artiste est guidé par une nécessité
intérieure par une volonté constante il
arrive à soumettre ces éléments tout à
fait différente de la plume que tient un
écrivain que sont pour un metteur en
scène une équipe des acteurs et de toute
manière je crois que le cinéma
bien qu'il ne soit pas fait comme le dit
souvent louis malle pour démontrer et
pour discourir dans la mesure où il
refuse de parler et où il préfére mentré
certaines choses permet tout à fait dans
un assez grand champ à l'explication de
texte
d'ailleurs ce qui explique que la
psychanalyse s'intéresse autant au
cinéma qu'à la littérature
oui je vous pose une dernière question
louis malle est ce que nous arrive pas
quelquefois de regretter de ne pas vous
exprimer
plus directement en écrivant eh bien oui
c'est une tentation qu'on a dans les
moments de de dépression quand on fait
un film parce que il est évident qu'un
écrivain qui a une plume et du papier a
des rapports directs immédiat rapide
avec eux entre ce qu'il a envie de dire
est ce qu'il dit il y avait des rapports
qui sont qui se mesure à la minute enfin
nous c'est tu ne sais pas c'est comme de
faire un enfant de faire un film ça ça
vous prend un temps fou
c'est très long c'est très difficile
c'est souvent très très douloureux et ça
se fait avec beaucoup de gens on parle
toujours des metteurs en scène on oublie
qu'un metteur en scène c'est il n'y rien
synap avec lui des gens qui travaillent
et qui prolonge et qui développe ses
idées ses thèmes et ses ses pensées
intimes et si vous voulez par moment
enfin on pense qu'on est un créateur on
pense qu'on est un peintre ou un
écrivain et je crois que par moments il
faut être aussi un chef de chantier à
l'architecte un architecte enfin pour
hui disons que ça d'une façon plus plus
élégantes mais en fait il faut être
vraiment comme un comme un homme qui est
sur le terrain et qui arrive à tous et
son idée à travers toutes les
vicissitudes toutes les erreurs tous les
changements
tous les tous les malentendus et ça je
crois que c'est finalement la vertu des
grands metteurs en scène c'est d'avoir
cette force qui leur permet de partir
d'une idée comme ça dans l'eure dans
leurs rêves et d'aboutir un an après un
film qui doit être le moins différents
possibles
enfin moi ce qui me ce qui m'encourage
et ce qui me pousse à continuer si vous
voulez c'est que l'écart entre ce dont
je rêve quand je pense à un film quand
j'imagine un film seul dans dans mon
bureau et je voudrais que ce rêve soit
le se rapproche de plus en plus de la
réalité que j'obtiens d'après quand je
vois le film et qui toujours évidemment
me déplaît me déçoit et que je voudrais
tellement plus près de moi la difference
diminue j'ai l'impression que la
différence diminue oui c'est pour ça que
nous avons aussi j'espère que peu à peu
ça ça collera ça colle merci